good afternoon my name is Stephanie
Kraus an attorney and candidate for an
mph here at the School of Public Health
with a concentration in law and health
policy today we welcome dr. Trevor
Mandel president of the global health
division at the bill and melinda gates
foundation since joining the Gates
Foundation in 2001 dr. Mandel leads the
foundations efforts in research and
development in vaccines drugs to address
major global health challenges in the
developing world these efforts harness
innovations in science and technology to
save lives from diseases that receive
too little attention and funding such as
AIDS malaria pneumonia and neglected
infectious diseases under his leadership
the Global Health Division works in
collaboration with a grantees and
partners to harness global health
solutions using platform technologies
dr. Mandel brings a wealth of experience
in healthcare and development to his
work in global health before joining the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation he
worked as head of the global development
at Novartis and was involved in clinical
research at both parke-davis and Pfizer
as a native of South Africa dr. Mandel
earned his bachelors and medical degrees
at the University of Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg he also studied mathematics
logic and philosophy as a Rhodes Scholar
at Oxford University and earned his PhD
in mathematics at the University of
Chicago before I turn this session over
to our moderator dr. Diane worth Richard
Pearson strong professor of infectious
disease and chair of the department of
immunology and infectious diseases
please join me in welcoming dr. Trevor
Mandel to the voices in leadership
series at the Harvard th Chan School of
Public Health
well dr. window welcome and thank you
very much for coming we're going to take
this opportunity to have a discussion
with you on leadership and on how you
view the challenges of leadership and
how throughout your career you've had a
had you had careers in different
settings you've been in academia you've
been in business and now you're at the
Gates Foundation and we'd like you to
comment on how kind of you've prepared
yourself for these leadership roles well
thanks Diane you know you're quite right
in terms of the very diverse
circumstances from the private sector
from academic settings to the Gates
Foundation but i think that there's
certain commonalities to to those
settings one is that these are all
political settings so I think that being
aware of the motivations of your
stakeholders and your partners and being
sensitive to that is something which you
can never forget in terms of being able
to work work matrix that you have I
think there's another thing that I've
learned and as I've look back and then
maybe it's something that's inherent or
maybe it's something that people can
actually learn about which is to the
extent that you perceived as being
someone who is territorial who has a
particular mission which is maybe
divergent from the best interests of the
entire organization that's a big
negative and to be able to make some
examples early on in your career where
you clearly state and you clearly
demonstrate that you're not like that I
think is critical interesting so um one
of the things that the students are
always interested in is is understanding
kind of what qualities you look for when
you're when you're picking leaders for
the organizations that you know sort of
sort of participants in the
organizations that you lead and how you
think about training people are
mentoring people toward leadership roles
you know generically die and there are
three things that I think that are
critical to selecting and thinking about
people one is obviously just competence
in the role you know what what people
are going to be doing the second thing
is a sense of real ambition but they are
truly ambitious and they want to push
things beyond maybe even the stated
balance and the third one would be
around a sense of integrity now those
are fairly personal and difficult things
to come to a decision on I find in in a
single meeting with someone's I'm often
when we meet candidates at the
foundation and people come in for
positions I'm usually in the mode at
least of the first meeting of you know
let's let's try and put this person in
the most positive light possible so in
the convenience we have afterwards and
people say well what did you think of
this candidate I'll be on the front end
you know as the cheerleader and saying I
thought that was fantastic candidate
they were enthusiastic and it will often
take the diversity of people to sort of
roll me back and say well would they be
a good fit in this regard or not but and
I also find that you need more than just
a telephone conversation or a single
half hour session to come to some
estimate on those types of criteria
great thank you so maybe now we'll move
a little bit to the to the questions of
global health so clearly you're leading
an organization that has a major impact
on global health on the direction of
global health research in particular and
implementation and I'm wondering sort of
how you think about the problems of
global health how you parse what the
foundation is going to be involved in
and and how you balance the various
competing priorities that was actually
one of the principal challenges that
that I confronted when i started with
with gates we had a number of strong
ideas about priorities in individual
areas
but we didn't have a adequate I thought
portfolio view of all the things that we
were doing so hundred different projects
we didn't have any way of adjudicating
is it better for us to invest in
improving the primary health care system
in the SU to very small country we could
make some impact or is it better to
invest in a novel TB vaccine which has
been so difficult to make and those seem
like such disparate I tumhari you
adjudicate across that sort of territory
so I felt that we needed some framework
of thinking about these things and only
as a guide because the the confidence in
precise estimates has to be somewhat
guarded so we started to think about
just the common measures things like
disability adjusted life years averted
for a particular intervention which you
can apply to an intervention you could
apply to a diagnostic you could apply to
a new vaccine and then also building and
of course because we live in this
constrained world of resource the
cost-effectiveness so how much would it
cost and we took as our measure bed nets
for malaria hundred dollars per
disability adjusted life year averted
and male surgical circumcision for
reducing HIV transmission which is
actually cost saving so we took two
known things out there that almost
everybody would agree are useful very
useful interventions and then we put
them across the rest of the portfolio
and said where do things fall out and
very quickly you know some things did
fall out so you know and they were very
positive project in some ways but we had
a look at them very carefully we looked
at for instance where would a hookworm
vaccine fall out in this mix of very big
entities very interesting scientific
project to get a hookworm vaccine a huge
part of the world's population in
developing countries impacted by this
but it's not just a hookworm vaccine you
know if we had something it was totally
curative eliminated hookworm permanent
that'd be one thing it was how would
that vaccine be versus the very
effective
drug campaigns the mass drug campaigns
that people use with very effective
drugs and it turns out actually not that
much so we had to take some actions like
that on our portfolio great I think it's
very interesting and I think perhaps one
of the other things too to comment on is
how you see global health evolving in
the time that you've been involved at
the Gates Foundation so how do you see
the approaches the thinking about global
health changing as we speak you know I
can give my own personal example from
your ultimate bosses Bill and Melinda
Gates when they announced in 2007 and a
meeting that they'd convened that they
were calling for the eradication of
malaria and of course there I was as a
basic scientist saying really the
eradication of malaria we've tried this
once um does it does it really make
sense but i think that is led to a
paradigm shift in the field that that
we're at least thinking about how to
eradicate malaria and what it would take
what are the various steps and i'm
wondering in terms of that so that was
considered at least in the malaria field
a very bold step at the time and the
question is how do you think global
health thinking is evolving as we speak
today are there such dramatic changes in
other areas no Diane I think actually
you you really on track with your
comments over there so to the extent
that if one looks back over the last
couple of decades in the health care
sector in general but in global health
in particular there been elements of
pessimism that anything could be done
because the infrastructure and the
situation in many of the region's that
we are most interested in would be so
difficult to work in or they would be
sort of millennial thinking about as
fantastic really radical malaria in five
years or we'll have you know nobody will
die from malaria by this year 2050 2015
right that was a that was a girl at one
point
so there was either the sort of
fantastical thinking or there was
extreme pessimism and and what I've seen
is people now starting to roll up their
sleeves and say well what are the
ambitious goals we have and Berlin will
underpin really at the forefront of
certainly challenging us in the
foundation on those and some of the
global health community as well but then
going the next step of saying and now
what are the practical plans whereby
you're going to actually execute on
these ambitious goals eradication of
malaria eradication of some of the other
neglected tropical diseases getting the
tools that we need for malaria
eradication and trying them out in some
easier circumstances but nobody with an
idea that there is a credible plan
whereby we will eradicate malaria in
five years now interesting time for the
fields um so in terms of let's move sort
of to education and preparation excuse
me in terms of from an educational
standpoint what's what's your sense of
what the the global health the public
health expert is going to need in a
decade is it going to be or or in two
decades is it the same kind of skills
that we have now are there additional
skills that people are going to need to
solve these major problems but we were
just chatting before the session yeh
around how multifunctional the problems
have become you know if you take the the
mantra that you have here from jeans to
the globe that truly is the spectrum of
where we're at so that requires
multifunctional disciplines not it
difficult to expect any one person is
going to master all of those so that one
is to think about a different type of
education I mean an exposure to the
complexity of the problems and a
sufficient understanding of the
components that you can access and you
can ask the right questions so I think
that that is a new pedagogy that hasn't
quite been worked out yet even within
the foundation ourselves as we think
about putting together these
multifunctional
means it's a challenge how do you get
people that have fundamentally different
training they've different way of
viewing the problems to work together on
a single problem it's a challenge we
face here and and certainly I think it's
it's one of the challenges that we've
identified here at the th-10 school
public health to to really focus on
training students you know Julio likes
to refer to students as t-shaped the
ideal student is t-shaped a deep
knowledge okay but the T part the
connection having knowledge that allows
you to interact you know in a functional
way with um with others who have
different in-depth knowledge and I think
that's it's really interesting visual
but I think it's exactly what you're
saying you need people who are experts
because without experts you won't you
won't be able to achieve what you need
but you need people who can understand
the importance of the other parts of of
disciplines and and expertise that needs
to be brought to a problem know exactly
and i would add you just from my own
experience there's a sort of a circuit
diagram like understanding of the
components and you may understand some
genetics and some toxicology on the path
what was so helpful to me was the work
which seemed completely tangential in
mathematics and complex dynamical
systems because you know some
understanding of how the nonlinearities
in a system actually can lead to
behaviors which are not obvious or were
not predicted I think is something which
whenever you put these more multi
functional groups together or you're
looking at the systems that we're trying
to impact in the world which about these
components that are operating and
interacting in nonlinear ways so some
sensitivity to the dynamical nature of
the world as opposed to just book
learning of individual components i
think is important
so in in terms I think it's about time
to open the questions to the audience so
I don't want to take all of dr.
Mondale's time so we'll will allow some
in the audience to ask questions we also
have some questions that have come in
via social media of some sort so are
there sergeant's in the room or I'll
start with one all right so one of the
questions that came in from students is
what can the nonprofit sector learn from
big business and you're an ideal person
I think to answer that since you've had
deep experience in both that I think
that it goes both ways I've learnt a
fantastic amount from you know the
people some of the people in the room
over here and from the partners that
we've had in the nonprofit sector we've
put a very different perspective and in
some ways some of the problems a little
bit more complex but certainly I think
that what I mentioned was in this
portfolio approach thinking about in the
for-profit sector of course you've got
some fairly simple measures of your
portfolio you can look at its value its
economic value and things that you do to
that port for you are going to alter
that that economic value now that that
can be it sounds simple but it can be a
very difficult thing when you're
projecting how valuable is this new drug
going to be in eight years time when
there's a different set ecosystem
different set of therapies that might be
already out there and there are many
competitors that are going to have
similar or going to have even more novel
compounds that projection as you know is
a difficult one within that context but
the idea that you are matching your
resources against a portfolio and trying
to allocate against what is most
productive in terms of the goals over
there which is to have the highest
economic value and return on their
portfolio the to us is to have the
highest human return on our portfolio
which we now measure in by the
some of the numbers that i mentioned
that has been a transferable type of
insight question i thank you very much
I'm Julia Brian alum of the Kennedy
School of Government question for you on
the the Ebola outbreak and just the
height of the spotlight that it put on
the the importance of Health System
strengthening and can you talk a little
bit about what the gates foundation's
thinking about that right now and how
you might be altering any of your
approaches to broaden your approach to
health system strengthening do you know
that that was there many lessons that
are going to come out of Ebola and we'll
get some of those breaking out at least
over the next couple of months leading
up to even the g7 meeting that that's
going to happen in June I think people
are starting to think very hard it's a
little bit premature because of course
that that situation there tragic
situation is not yet over so one
shouldn't encourage people to start
thinking about all these things before
we've dealt with it one immediate thing
from our perspective you know we
initially had committed a fairly
significant amount of acute funding into
this about 50 million of which probably
ended up being more than that but was
how the systems for response to
emergencies like this to the extent that
they had already been set up were not
able to very rapidly inflexibly deploy
funding even fairly small amounts of
money there was a committee a research
committee which was set up at wh 0 that
we needed to have that done very
urgently and it was a question would
this go through some couple of months
funding process just to set up an expert
group that could get together and give
us information on where we should go on
the research agenda and we were able to
step in and you know within days be able
to fund that so from from our
perspective and what I saw was the
fungibility and the flexibility of our
funding we were able to fill some of the
gaps in the system where there was
funding in place very large amounts of
funny
in place but it was fairly rigid so I
think at a sort of a global system for
emergency response we need to think more
systematically about how we actually
have that interaction now the healthcare
situation in country clearly all of the
mechanisms whereby this epidemic is
being dealt with could have been dealt
with so much more effectively with even
a modicum of improvement in those those
healthcare systems and we know that some
of the places Uganda or the Democratic
Republic of Congo where they are being
more frequent Ebola outbreaks even
though some of the infrastructure they
may not be fantastic have been able to
certainly have been adequate to dealing
with the problem it just re emphasizes
for us that you know whatever we could
do on the treatment side let's say and I
think I'm pretty hopeful we're going to
come up with some effective therapies
out of this situation whether it be the
antibody or even drug therapies and
we'll see about a vaccine but things
that would need to be delivered by
people in a decent care setting without
that being in place we can have you know
the antibody or the Magic Bullet drug
but being able to deliver that is going
to be the final frontier and the
obstacle so I think that we are very
focused on on that none it's a bit of a
wake-up call another question that that
comes up not just about global health
but but it does come up about how the
research you know industry how the
research infrastructure is funded in the
US and and I think for many students and
fellows now they're looking at the NIH
budget as being flat or even going down
in real dollars and that's really been
the place that the vast majority of
fundamental research in the United
States and has been funded over since
the the you know since the middle of the
last century and I think many of us see
that that situation may be permanently
changed there's there's really a change
and I'm wondering
how you from the foundation side think
about that problem and what kinds of
things uh foundations like the Gates
Foundation can do to help you know help
advocate for additional government
funding I think that even with the
vastness of the Gates Foundation the
federal government still the research
infrastructure and the research the
scientific infrastructure and the
federal government is still of course
much greater well we are you know just
generically advocates and huge believers
in the role of public funding of basic
research I think what we can do and what
we have been doing in fact we were just
on my team was on a call with a senior
team from the NIH just yesterday we
started up a process last year after
Bill Gates gave a lecture at the NIH
bombs lecture how we could better align
what we were doing so there would be
complementarity and not redundancy and
it occurs in two areas one was and this
is in the global health area now I would
say that you know why exactly with the
NIH be in global health Ebola is a great
example of why it actually is important
to be engaged in global health but to
the extent that we got two big funders
probably the two biggest funders of the
global health research agenda we had no
notions of what our respective
portfolios were and whether there was
redundancy whether we were potentially
funding the same people hopefully not
for the same activities but we didn't
know that and I think that we have now a
good sense of that we had that process
the other thing is that as much as we
see the NIH funding your long-term basic
research there is a certain category of
research which is kind of the crazy
stuff just somebody a high school
student has a new idea for a maybe an
iphone app that's going to be revolution
there was such an example who funds that
and that's one of the things that we
designed our Grand Challenges
exploration these
hundred-thousand-dollar grants that you
can get with a two page application
if you've got a great idea and that is
sort of the crazy stuff and we've seen
actually now some great examples of
interesting things coming out of that so
that sort of complements the NIH and
they're probably the NIH would would not
find that okay yes we have a related
question sent in from the early online
audience how have you dealt with the
challenges of our stable financial and
funding environment at the foundation
and as you may know many of our students
are going to work in the nonprofit
sector so how would you suggest students
going into the nonprofit sector think
about funding challenges in their own
organizations thank you well you know
they clearly has been a constrained
funding source for for global health
which has been tied up with the larger
trends that we've talked about over here
so I wouldn't say that global health was
uniquely targeted but it does seem that
in some cases when people are
considering you know overseas direct
investments and the like that it comes
up as in in some countries in some
settings as one of the first things that
suggest that as might be something that
could be cut from from from the budgets
so we've seen our partners and
particulars has impacted us through our
partner organizations the product
development partners for instance but
other partners as well as their funding
sources their diversified funding
sources are pretty much shrunk and in
some cases we've become the major
funders of organizations that used to
have fifty plus percent of the funding
from a diversity of sources at that
that's a huge challenge for those
organizations because we would like them
to be independent and to have this
diversity of funding so it's
necessitated a number of sort of hard
discussions in terms of you know is this
entity viable do we go forward with us
are the other ways that that we could do
this kind of work in terms of somebody
going into the philanthropic or the
not-for-profit sector now with the
funding constraints that exist I I
wouldn't be totally pessimist
I think that some of the trends
particularly from philanthropy and the
way that we saw some philanthropists
drawn into the Ebola crisis you know
persons with tremendous personal wealth
who really you know one of the first
types of investments they've made at
this kind of level that that being very
exciting and I think that that we just
have to think of ways of translating
some of that funding it's always easy in
some ways to get funding for an acute
crisis that everybody knows and there's
on the front pages of the newspaper but
how do we and this has been one of the
things that I found most remarkable we
have crises you know which are of a
greater dimension than Ebola going on
every day in the countries in which we
work how do we get the this border group
of philanthropists now to know about and
actually to participate in that kind of
funny that's a vast untapped source of
funding bet I think maybe leading on
from Ebola and one of the lessons we've
learned we can actually tap into very
thank you so much for coming and for
your words of wisdom one of the things
that we appreciate tremendously about
not least the Ebola crisis but the
general question is capacity in
developing countries and one of the
things this school takes pride in is
that about a third of our students come
from overseas increasingly from
developing countries there's money refer
research there's money for many other
things it is really difficult to get
money for training in public health and
other forms of advanced biomedical
science for people who are needed to
provide leadership in developing
countries what's the perception of the
foundation in where that capacity is
going to come from
berry thanks for the question it is a
difficult question and we've looked at
this quite hard because there's the
element of training of people from
developing countries and that is
absolutely critical there's also the
element of developing an infrastructure
in those countries so that the train
people will have a good home to return
to and will be excited to go back and
work in their countries and have the
kinds of opportunities that they would
like over there and I've been very
focused on and at least in the global
health perspective focused on that
aspect of the training question so what
happens in some ways after training and
I think that would also enrich the pool
of people who are really applicants for
being trained a couple of things are
happening on that front though and
because I think everybody is acutely
aware of that issue with the Wellcome
Trust and with the British government
we've established this initiative around
accelerating excellence in science in
Africa where we want to get away from
the paradigm of people outside of Africa
making grants or selecting African
scientists for funding and whereby we
would have an entity like the African
Academy of Sciences have a fund which
they can use to select themselves
African scientists for training and for
funding I think they've been other
initiatives just in in South Africa you
know there's be there was a big
initiative to reform the medical
research council there and change its
structure and make it a much more
efficient organization and we were able
to step in and provide some funding
which was then matched by the Ministry
of Finance and that's always the trick
because within countries there's the
Ministry of Health or ministry of
science they often don't have a lot of
money the Ministry of Finance on the
other hand does so that comes down to
marshaling the economic arguments of the
benefits for African countries to
allocate a what for them is a
significant proportion of their budget
to science and to science training
David David hunter th town school so
Trevor I'm sure you saw the op-ed piece
that Bill Gates wrote in The New York
Times recently in the perspective New
England Journal just pointing out how
ill-prepared we are in terms of pandemic
preparedness and obviously stimulated by
Ebola we can imagine more effective
health systems would have provided
earlier warning but they still probably
in that setting would have needed
substantial external help but who knew
that medicine frontiere was the world's
first responders or ambulance brigade
and it seemed like there was a call for
something like that that would be kind
of transnational maybe have certain
powers beyond the National Health
Regulations but of course there are
delicate issues of national sovereignty
etc when the next pandemic comes are we
going to be better prepared than we've
been for past pandemics I am Optimus II
actually that we will be I only thing I
worry about is that that may take some
years to put all the structures in place
because we're talking about some fairly
substantial changes to the way that
global health is is governed and these
structures of type of task force that
could be maintained and could be
parachuted into these urgent areas will
take a while to construct and to Train I
would be worried about what happens if
we have a influenza epidemic in the next
shorter while before the structures are
in place so there is that issue I do
think that there are a couple of things
in the background that I've certainly
focused on and this comes around to
national sovereignty some of the
critical decisions that are taken in
terms of interventions that are deployed
and should be deployed because as you
saw with Ebola they were a there was a
hue and cry about a dozen different
claim to be effective interventions that
should be deployed urgently and in fact
that were deployed in Ebola patients
outside of the impact
countries very readily who adjudicates
that in the countries and to the extent
do we have capacity in the ministries of
health in the regulatory systems in
those countries to be able to make that
adjudication because you can make that
adjudication in Geneva but in some ways
it doesn't necessarily have impact in a
country which is very distant from
Geneva in terms of driving action even
though the group in Geneva is probably
empowered in terms of the World Health
Association legislation and also has the
scientific capability to make some of
the determinations so I think we have to
look very carefully at the regulatory
systems in the countries that may be
impacted in in this regard with the
example of these three countries and
also some of the efforts towards
harmonized religious systems that might
be able to aggregate very difficult to
see that we could have an FDA in every
country in Africa anytime soon but can
we have regional harmonized regulatory
bodies which would have considerable
capability an ability in such a crisis
and in future to be able to do that in
East Africa East African harmonized
region already is a great example of
that and i think that there's talk now
about ecowas in West Africa also going
in that direction so we are very
supportive of that that harmonization
from the perspective that we can then
have very good local decision-making
that will drive action I think that that
brings us to this this broader question
it's not just Ebola that doesn't respect
borders but it's you know every
infectious diseases malaria the disease
that I work on not only doesn't respect
borders but there are mosquitoes that
can carry it across borders or people
carrying it across borders so in general
do you see a shift in global governance
of of disease of Health is how how's
that tension going to work and what is
what role do organizations like the
Gates Foundation play both in developing
the thinking but also subsequently in
the implementation of this
this kind of idea I do see this
evolution diane and i think that the
World Health Organization which is
really a normative organization plays a
critical role in setting forward you
know rational policies but translating
them into action requires something
which is much more local so either it is
capacity within directly within country
in the Ministry of Health and as I've
said that to have that same level of
capacity in many many countries is a
tall order we'll get there eventually
but that take a long time in the interim
is there this middle layer that we can
put in place where we have regional
significant organizations which can
translate the types of policies that the
World Health Organization would put
forward into the relevant regional terms
and reference so um one of the things
that we've talked about this morning is
this idea of the Gates Foundation has
partnerships with many organizations and
I wondered if you might comment on sort
of your experience with partnerships
what you think works what does it work
what kinds of issues come up that that
would be a longest but let's try and
prioritize on some of these items over
here you know one I think would just be
people would need to understand our
philosophy so as much as we've grown as
an organization in terms of our actual
organizational size tremendously about
15 years now we are heading towards a
steady state of you know about 1500
people from the few people who started
in Bill Gates seniors placement so
that's a that's a tremendous increase
but they spread across many different
programs including the u.s. programs and
agriculture and other things
nevertheless that that is a very small
group to execute the portfolio that we
participate in it's not everything that
we own a net portfolio we try and
support the entire global health
portfolio that's a very small group so
we are always going to be an
organization that
is going to mostly operate through
partners so I think that they things
with that that understanding because
there's always the sense particularly
the partners where we all say the
majority funder to what extent do we not
get into the negative dynamic of as a
majority funder do we have too much
stake in where that entity is going and
the decisions they're making and to what
extent tab we build the capabilities for
them to really be independent and
effective in the world that's our best
outcome so that's a i think a recurrent
dialogue with our partners is how do we
encourage their independent action based
on good capabilities as opposed to say
us convening expert groups and somehow
being the funnel for expert advice going
out to the global health world you know
with other partners it's interesting to
me we only sometimes need one effective
champion in a partner organization and
we can think of some of the
organization's we work with as difficult
to change moving slowly but it only
takes is one champion and an effective
person who is grown up in that
organization and knows how to play the
wheels of power over there to just cut
through things you know we've seen
through this in the regulatory reform
the pre-qualification and the world
health organization which has really in
the last 18 months undergone a sea
change in terms of a much more rational
and efficient system of putting products
into the global health space and it's
come about from you know one great
partner we had within the organization
you took this up and was championed by
the director-general so in fact I think
you're about to have a forum in Seattle
with your global partners and does that
have a theme you I understand you do
this every year right we fortunate
enough to be able to have this forum
which we call our partners for them and
it said various names product
development partners forum this year
it's a global forum because it truly
cuts across not just folks
involved in product development but a
vast array of people it'll be eight
hundred to a thousand people you know
who are deeply involved in global health
from government ministers to the World
Health Organization all of our product
development partners will be there so
it's a tremendous convening to actually
have and most of the values in the side
meetings when you can pull groups
together and come to to some types of
conclusions you know one of the things
that we've been working on so how do we
pull that group together how do how do
we put out one of the directions that
we're heading in and we come back to
this recurrent thorny issue of data and
what do we do with this we've been a big
source of the generation of healthcare
data but we've certainly not solved the
problem of the fact that that data is
siloed it's an archipelago of data out
there of little data islands that
persist for certain periods of time and
there's no integration around that so in
the to the extent that I see data only
as useful to the that it leads to
actions and decisions that being the
only use of generating data but in some
ways going directly from primary data in
the field to action and decisions which
may be government policies is too big a
step so we need an integrative layer we
need a model in between which distills
the data in some rational way whether it
is a dynamical model or it is a
geospatial map of malaria incidence and
prevalence and strains even will be
important there needs to be this
synthetic layer in between before you
can easily go to a health ministry and
say look we've got this data this is
what it's telling us that let me show
you what it's like and that's a little
bit around what we're going to talk
about at the session at least for part
of the session and we're thinking about
ways of you know bringing this back to
individual people and we're thinking of
the narrative of a woman who 15 years
ago in an African village gave birth to
a young girl and
you know what would the health care
system elements be the Chi confronted
not being seen by the health care system
and at home delivery what would her
daughter's future be in 15 years time
and that's the sort of narrative arc we
think about in that future world it's
almost an intentional envisioning of the
future in the 15-year future what would
we like her daughter to be able to
access when she is self gives delivery
in 15 years time Marcia I want to follow
up on a topic that you just mentioned so
you have the primary data and then you
would like to create this layer that
digests the data and then killing form
so some countries are not even fortunate
to have the primary data so you don't
have a chance to come up with this layer
just the data are not there is the
foundation doing something towards that
now or is planning to do in the near
future to actually address this major
need of having the primary data to then
have something else to inform pulse yes
yes very not very definitely yes because
as much as we've committed to the
synthetic layer I completely agree with
you that in that that is really
guesswork and a huge extrapolation if
you look at the conference balance on
our estimates they drawn from
neighboring countries and neighboring
regions even so we really do not know
the state exactly in every province of
you know dr see for instance of where
there's sleeping sickness african
trypanosomiasis and we need to invest in
that and we're looking at a system
whereby each of the regions the
significant regions would it minimally
have a reference center center of
excellence that would be able to do
sophisticated cross pathogen
surveillance collecting a primary data
from a sufficient sampling pool that it
would not be representative of that
region to the extent could that be a
network of you know 50 of
reference centers that's that's a lot i
think it's going to have to be less than
that so we're going to have to integrate
this this notion and we've had some
fairly advanced discussions on this with
the existing networks it's not to say
that there are no networks but it
happens to be that they are not networks
which are great in exactly the places
where we don't have the data so our
drive over here would be not to be
redundant with the existing networks but
actually to think about putting these
reference centers exactly in the regions
and countries where we have the greatest
difficulty in getting good data right I
think we have time for one last short
question right hi I'm Alex am I am
actually from the other side of Africa
from Tunisia and a fact you have a
medical school so so today we with the
gates foundation work with hme we they
paved the way to understand that the
disease are not following the trend that
global health actors put in their agenda
as an example actually for instance in
my country for women the highest rate of
Daly's related to depression and
unfortunately the problem that the
healthcare system is not actually
prepared to do that and to handle this
situation and it's not also prepared
from the global health perspective with
actors are not really following that
path they're more interested about
infectious disease hiv/aids which still
an important issue so my question is how
the Case Foundation now perceive that
movement and and who are the actors who
may probably be able to solve the issues
on the shirt midterm and what kind of
investment is actually the Gates
Foundation would put probably in the
next few years or so we've certainly
been very significant supporters of this
ability to disaggregate the total burden
of disease into its components the
global burden of disease effort
unfortunately the circumstance that you
speak to and the irrationality of
healthcare allocation happens as much
almost in the developed countries as it
does in developing countries so you know
we have a lot to fit is a global problem
to fix and not such an easy one we often
get the question
in terms of why would we have a
continuing focus on infectious disease
when we know that non-communicable
diseases on our rising as a very major
element of the disease burden even in
developing countries I think that for
now at least when we look at the poorest
countries in the world it remains the
case as much as there is an emerging
non-communicable disease burden over
there infectious disease is a huge and
unsolved problem for them so we more of
a sense right now that we need to fix
the problem we started with in the most
countries most lacking in infrastructure
first when we have you know got to a
certain point in that then we would have
to come back to this this issue of a
more rational allocation to the entities
mental health is a huge problem it comes
up in all the lists and all the tables
very high we do have to think about you
know whether we have effective
interventions and some of them are very
cost intense intensive in terms of
infrastructure is are going to have to
gather up because of time I'm sorry
we're going to ask you to perhaps a
couple of takeaway messages for the
group and then we'll be able to conclude
Thanks diet no and you can see that that
is a question on priorities which is
close to our mission and our heart but
you know when I just look at my
trajectory over here and in terms of
what I see across the world in terms of
the many global health groups that I
meet with and actually many of these
students that I love to meet with like
yourselves the only thing that I can
think about is that I was crazy not to
have done what I'm doing now 20 years
ago so in terms of whether this is a
positive world to enter into or it's
something on a decline to get into
global health from the perspective of
the nonprofit sector I think is the most
satisfying career you can ever imagine
in any of the healthcare space and it
talks anything that I conceived
be done before it's God if you like
complex problems it's got every
dimension of a complex problem so I can
only encourage you to in some ways look
beyond as I think it is rational to do
some of these issues we raised around
the immediate funding crisis there is
such a desperation out there and I see
such an emerging global consensus that
we should actually do something about
this and we should do something now and
not have this wait for another
generation that I do believe will
transcend that funding crisis whether it
be by philanthropist other means so you
know I would focus in terms of what
you're thinking about developing your
big ideas because that's part of the
ambition and you know putting yourselves
in in front of organizations that you
want to be with and do work that will
give you an incredible legacy thank you
very much dr. mundo with that I remind
everybody that world malaria day is
coming up in two weeks and just to
remind I think everybody of the advances
made and the declaration by Bill and
Melinda Gates has there has been as a
result of that I think a focus on
applying the tools that we have now and
finding the new tools this is an example
of how an organization like the gates
foundation under the leadership we've
seen here can actually change the world
so I agree it's a very exciting time to
be in the field and we really appreciate
you coming to visit great thank you
you